プラの皆さん底便とって好きですかチョコミントずて僕めちゃくちゃ好き嫌い分かれる
最強の食べ物だと思うんですよね本当に好きな人は好きっていうふうに嫌いな人は嫌い
っていう
こんなにおごれるもありましたが今までで僕あまりにその好き嫌いの分かれ方が以上線
って気になってアンケートをとってみたんですけども
twitter でアンケートをとってみた結果好きで
で美味しいっていう人は39%ちょっとメリーといったが41%
これわかんないですけどなんか20%すごくないですか39%とは40%ってホは人間
人類の半分の人が好き半分の人は嫌い
えーこんなに好き嫌いが分かれたのんあるかなと思っています
すごいと思いましたなんで逆に言うと好きな人はめちゃくちゃそこ民時ですし嫌い
めちゃ素子と無理っていう
がある意味逆にが一番おいしいんじゃないかとうまく言えないんですけどもうゼロが
咲く花みたいなもんだと思うんですよ無理な人からすると無理だなって言われるんです
よねもう
好きな人からすると
湿気も式なんですよそしてご覧くださいチョコミントアーチと8カ所がこのようにどれ
だけあることが近くのコンビニでかるーく買ってきたんですけどそれだけでもこんなに
種類があるんですよ
ああ常に私は
チョコミント好きですチョコミントに全然ちょっとお話しましょうチョコミントとは
日本だと1974年からチョコミントで振れば入ったみたいで当時チョコミントという
言葉が出たときはミントということは広く知られておらずハッカハッカという言葉で
売られていたことが多かったみたいですそうソミントって何かと言いますと
学名だと麺たって言うんです切りさ4
今に登場するニーズの免停に由来する理由がわかりませんミントの葉っぱには総会及び
ねぇ量を冷やす感じを与える面工具が風が吹くているためハーブや料理カクテルお菓子
2とするものによく使われるらしいですけど今日のバーガーミント好きな人に向けて
作っている動画ですきれないとも良かったらこれを見てちょっと食べてみようかなとか
思ってみたら嬉しいですチョコみんなもということ
残念って人いたらぜひこの動画を機会に食べてみてください上で1個ずつ食べてみ
ましょう
まず王道キットカットのチョコミントいただきます
甘いカントリーマアムチョコミントいただきますまあチョコラミントキャンディーだっ
たらすげーチョコミントキャンディーまであるんですねおっきいチョコミントを
いただきます
まあチョコミントグランツ
メイクチョコミントん
まあカントリーまあの蝶ちょこみんとうわぁこんな
なんて呼ぶんだと多分ルックだと思いますねー
[音楽]
ブーブー1個 air
って予選後半チョコミントになりすぎて味が分からなくなりました
てない私は今ここにあるすべてのチョコミントを食べて思ったことがあります
持っていた
全部目ここで私は思いついていいくら美味しいとはやっぱりチョコミントから払うと
あるんですよねミント感が強すぎるとめっちゃスースーするチョコミントになったら
いいなの民と言わ目にすると普通になんかあんまりせずしないけどおいしいチョコ
ミントになったりチョコミント味といいでもいろんな要素があるわけですよ
頑張ってる混ぜまあ全ての庶民党を混ぜることによって再購入しチョコミントのチョコ
ミントができるのかなと思いまして
アイスもあるんだったのーアイスもチョコも全て含めすべてのチョコミントを一つに
合体させた時史上最強に美味しチョコミントの枷ができるんじゃないかと思いますね
全部
a 混ぜまあ
待って8 a 8 a お酒私が今からやることがどういう結果を生むのかは分から
ないちょっとしたらまずいかもしれないけど
少なくとも
僕は食べてみちゃいまいと思うんだけど頑張ってに入りすぎるとバランス能力なんで
んあ各自適量入れましょうって言うとしたけどもう無理になっちゃっ
んだあああああ
ダウンっ tan
jan 10
want you つの三大ダメら使うよりマーニャバーイ
[音楽]
あーちょっとグロいな二だいたいみんなを乗せぐらいの量でお菓子を入れました
ん
うまいかもしれないで多分相手がめちゃくちゃ入ってるね襲われなんですけどもう
チョコミントシェイクみたいな感じになるのかなぁと思いますお楽しみ今妻
バー
塗りました日本ってうまいぞ多分クラスの皆さん意外と固いなあと加瀬が多かったから
ちょっとかバグになっちゃったもんないった立しっかり落ちてきていますただて
ちょこん人たちの協力によってロードような的なチョコミントシェフができるの
でしょうか
さあ今0時に入場です皆さん大きな鉢にお迎えください
遅いの正職音が入ってるか柔らかくなるなと思うんですけどを持っているかたいですね
出ました
こちらが現在町民状態の誇る決着でおっ
[音楽]
チョコミントの色はどこに行ったそこで水色の掛け合いがちょっとインスタ倍とかする
かなと思ってそこチョコミントの魅力の1つかなと思ったんですけど見てる所した
ただ大事なのは話ですいただきます
ん
me
初心者おいしいでなが多分これで美味しいというとてもチョコミント次の日にかけて
いくつですね
薬はベースはちょっとですね非常にチョコっぽくなっちゃいますだからやっぱその清涼
感とかスーツしてる感があってとても食べやすいです
ただ見た目は砂利ですねまっちょこみんと見た目の良さもウリの一つなんでしょうが
ちょっともったいないなと思いました
ただで全然食べれるかこれは是非ともねチョコミント時の皆さんには食べていたら
たい逸品でございましたとっても美味しいですとっても今回作ったから美味しいんです
けどもまぁこれを一言でまとめると混ぜないほうがいい
[音楽]
me
あっはぁ